هناك اشتباكات في الخرطوم دعونا نتابع هذه
الصور الجويه والتي تظهر مواقع الاشتباكات
في الخرطوم لهذا اليوم نشاهد الدخان
يتصاعد من تلك المنطقه تحديدا في اكثر من
منطقه حقيقه وهذا ما ذكروا قبل قليل مراسل
العربيه فيما يتعلق بوجود اشتباكات باكثر
من بقعه في الخرطوم كنا نتحدث ايضا عن
اشتباك وقع في جلد جسر الحلفايه كان هناك
اشتباكات لا زالت مستمره حتى وقت التغطيه
قبل دقائق من الان منطقه المطار منذ بدايه
الازمه كانت مشتعله لا زالت مشتعله رغم
الهدنه نشاهد الان انه الاشتباكات تستمر
هناك والدخان لازال يتصاعد بكثافه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات